all right welcome back to this week in
startups it's our special the next
unicorns uh you can see
daphne kohler from incitro and nikki
pekket from homebound on the first two
episodes and gary beasley is our guest
today from roof
stock uh s-t-o-c-k so tell us what is
roof stock
and uh how do you make money we're
a marketplace for residential housing
that can be traded through our platform
completely online so think about us a
bit like an amazon for houses
we bring suppliers of homes together who
want to sell them
and and buyers of homes who want to buy
them and we do all the work
through our platform so we really sort
of turn the transaction process upside
down
by breaking down the geographic barriers
to real estate investing so you could be
sitting in
hillsborough buying homes in um
you know memphis or anywhere in the u.s
with all the information that you need
at your fingertips so that's really the
idea is to break down those geographic
barriers
and and have a completely sort of
digital
experience and so we make money by
charging buyers and sellers a fee
principally sellers a fee as as
transactions happen through the site and
then we also charge a small
fee to the the buy side what is that oh
50 basis points to the buy side so if i
buy a million dollar home
uh one percent of that would be 10 50
base points would be 5 000. so let's pay
you 5 000
for buying the million dollar home what
would you have done as a buyer of homes
previously because is there
you're still paying the real estate
agent fees and that kind of stuff no
no that's your entire cost as a buyer
and and what
we do is that that really kind of
compensates us for
the work that we do preparing homes for
sale we do all the diligence and pay for
that
and then the seller is putting this the
seller puts this stuff online
uh with you and you act as the broker
selling it correct so think about it if
um if you have a home and we don't sell
a lot of million dollar homes our
platform's really designed for
a hundred to three hundred thousand
dollar homes um
in in lower cost markets around the us
but so take a take a typical 150
000 home with a tenant in it so you're
buying a home that's already leased
typically that's our model so we vet the
the home itself with an
inspection we vet local property
managers and we've got the tenant
and and create a diligence room for you
so you can you see all that information
uh up front and we charge sellers
typically three percent
to sell and that's the entire cost to
the seller and the seller doesn't have
to vacate the home to sell it
so we then pay for the diligence we
bring buyers to the table
and facilitate those transactions and so
um
i was just looking yesterday the average
home that sells through our platform
goes under contract in less than 10 days
so
that we have very good liquidity because
we're bringing buyers from really all
over the world
to buying these homes that are packaged
up nicely
that could be purchased from anywhere uh
so if i was
a real estate investor and i wanted to
do this previously i would have probably
picked
a house that's within whatever you know
an hour's drive so i can manage it or i
can deal with vendors there
which means i'm buying in the same if
i'm an investor i'm buying in the same
region which means
it's going to be super highly correlated
and i probably if i could afford to buy
one i probably own an expensive house in
that area
so it doesn't give me any
diversification and what are the chances
that the place i've chosen to live as an
affluent person
say los angeles new york san francisco
chicago
is the place that's going to appreciate
most next that's probably not correct
is that right we hit the nail on the
head so this this allows you to
diversify
over 70 percent of homes of
investment homes are owned within an
hour drive of where the the resident
lives the investor lives
so by breaking that mold you could be
buying in lower cost markets for the
cost the price of one home
within an hour's drive of you jason you
could buy three four five homes in
another part
of the country that have better yield or
uncorrelated
as you pointed out because if you do
have a downturn
in the bay area or in any of the other
places it typically affects your job
your primary home equity and your
secondary home equity if it's there so
you're just getting walloped
uh by the same tidal wave if it does in
fact come as opposed to being
diversified which is the whole point of
this
now if i were to buy in a place i don't
know i thought arizona or
texas or houston you know with the big
boom areas i'm not sure if that's still
correct
and i wanted to buy in those suburbs if
i
prior to using roof stock i would have
to get on a plane or hire a consultant
to do that
yeah the old old way is you would
probably look online and see a bunch of
listings that might be for sale
you would line up a bunch of tours
in advance by talking to a bunch of
listing agents and then you would fly
to houston or fly to atlanta and you
would go look at houses
you'd make a bunch of offers and
hopefully get something and then once
you get something you would find a
contractor
you'd find a property manager and you
try to
coordinate all this remotely which is
quite difficult
so what we've done is essentially
created the real estate investment cloud
if you will you pull into our
infrastructure and you
and you never have to leave your couch
you can do all the underwriting from
there
you could you know find your select your
property manager from there
do all your research from there all
that's all that's provided for you and
these homes are typically already
occupied so you don't have upfront
renovations
that are that are typical if you're
buying a house that needs a lot of work
but even so if it does need work we have
local contractor relationships
and we certify local property managers
so you can outsource the day-to-day
uh management and view it much more like
an investment
as opposed to trying to do something the
old-school way of
flying there and just trying to buy
houses so i buy 150k house you get three
and a half percent of that or so
so that means you make your five six k
uh which is fine it sounds like you you
earn that uh
obviously by vetting them and vetting
the tenant
what does vetting the tenant in this
case be because my understanding is when
you're buying homes they're worth more
when there's not a tenant
but you're saying that you're
diligencing the tenant
so does that mean it's worth more with
the tenant that's been diligenced how
does that work
i would say what we try to do is take
what historically has been a liability
uh and turn it into an asset so if
you're an investor and you wanna
and you want a rental home you could buy
a vacant home
and have an estimate of what the rent is
and then get put a tenant in there
or you could buy a home that already has
a tenant in it that's been inspected at
where we've reviewed the tenant payment
history and the criteria for getting the
tenant
approved in that home and you're
stepping into something that has
arguably more certainty than by even
buying a vacant home
the reason that that having a buying a
tenant occupied home in the past is
viewed
as a liability is often oftentimes those
were homes that might be
have been foreclosed on where there's a
the old
borrower might be living in there rent
free and
they won't leave or you don't know
anything about the tenant that's in
there
so it's high risk there could be some
liability and you remove that
if you're buying something off the mls
that has a tenant in it
you're probably not going to have a lot
of information on it so when you buy
something off roof stock because we get
access to all that information
we do the inspections the tenant review
all that we make it all available to you
so it actually de-risks it and so in
some ways a lot of people who are buying
the homes from us view
having a tenant in place oftentimes with
six or more months left on their lease
is a real asset and so
in many cases we're finding the tenanted
assets are worth
more because you don't have any vacancy
yeah
doesn't it also make the price of the
home more
accurate if you actually have the tenant
in there because i could see a real
estate broker saying yeah you'll get
seven thousand for this house
and then you know a year in rent or
whatever and or seventeen thousand a
year and rent for this house but the
reality is you're gonna get 14.
or whatever it is yeah yeah so it's it's
that
it's verified by the market right
there's a there's a tenant in there
um you want to make sure that it wasn't
a sweetheart deal and it wasn't
the guy's brother-in-law or something
like that right they got four months
free and
they're paying a above market rent and
we helped check that anyway